bevor es losgeht eine kleine Sache wenn
euch die Folge gefallen hat dann sind
wir euch so dankbar wenn ihr uns fünf
Sterne da lasst ganz egal wo ihr hört
gebt uns gern die Top-Bewertung folgt
uns und schaltet die Benachrichtigung
ein Danke Danke jetzt geht's los
hallo mein Name ist Sky du Mont und ich
präsentiere euch den dunklen Januar ein
Tatort Deutschland Spezial jeden Tag ein
neuer Kriminalfall
hallo und schön dass ihr auch heute
wieder dabei seid ich bin Natalie Strauß
und wenn ich nicht hinter dem Podcast
Mikrofon sitze stehe ich in Hamburg im
Radio Studio auch heute ist Mirko
Kasimir Sprecher und moderationskollege
wieder an meiner Seite dank seiner
fantastischen Stimme tauchen wir auch
heute wieder tief ein in einem
spannenden Kriminalfall und die
schnellen Fakten verschaffen mir jetzt
schon ein Kloß im Hals ein totes Kind
der Mörder ist ein junger Mann aus dem
Bekanntenkreis und der Polizei
Vizepräsident steht später unter Vater
Verdacht
jetzt kommst du hey Natalie schön dich
zu sehen und auch von mir ein Hallo an
alle Podcast Hörerinnen und Hörer die
sich mit uns in einen neuen Fall stürzen
es ist der 27 September 2002 in
Frankfurt am Main der letzte Schultag
vor den Herbstferien
der elfjährige Bankiers Sohn Jakob von
Metzler ist nach der Schule auf dem
Heimweg er hat nur ganz kurz Unterricht
und freut sich denn morgen soll es in
den Urlaub gehen
wie immer steigt er in den Bus und fährt
nach Hause das letzte kurze Stück geht
er zu Fuß
wenige hundert Meter vor seinem
Elternhaus hält ein Auto neben mir
ein junger Mann lässt das Fenster runter
die beiden tauschen sich kurz aus
Jakob öffnet die hintere Autotür und
steigt ein
es ist 10:30 Uhr
Jakob wird nicht mehr nach Hause kommen
der junge Mann Magnus gevken ist ein
bekannter seiner Schwester und soll an
diesem Vormittag Jakobs Mörder werden
das ist mitunter das wirklich furchtbare
an dieser Geschichte Magnus geffgen und
Jakob kennen sich und deshalb steigt der
Junge ohne nachzudenken bei dem
27-Jährigen ins Auto
Magnus soll zu Jakob gesagt haben seine
Schwester Elena habe ihre Jacke bei ihm
vergessen und ob er nicht kurz mitkommen
möchte um sie abzuholen um zurückzugeben
natürlich sagt Jakob und steigt ein
gegen Mittag findet Familie von Metzler
einen Erpresserbrief im Garten
gefordert werden eine Million Euro die
drei Tage später nachts abgelegt werden
sollen erst dann werde Jakob
freigelassen
der Vater von Jakob Friedrich von
Metzler leitet eine der ältesten
Privatbanken der Republik die Familie
ist sehr wohlhabend prahlt aber nicht
damit nur selten sieht man sie in der
Öffentlichkeit von Metzler ist
wahnsinnig gut vernetzt
die Forderungen im Erpresser schreiben
keine Polizei
ignoriert er und telefoniert schon eine
Stunde später mit dem Chef des
Landeskriminalamts und danach mit dem
Vizepräsidenten des Frankfurter
Polizeipräsidiums Wolfgang gaschner
einem der besten Polizisten des Landes
auf die Schnelle wird die
ermittlungstruppe Luisa zusammengestellt
ab jetzt gilt Alarmzustand alle
verfügbaren Kräfte werden in die
Ermittlungsarbeiten eingebunden
zunächst sind die Möglichkeiten aber
begrenzt man beginnt im unmittelbaren
Umfeld der Familie jeder noch so kleine
Hinweis wird Wagen genommen
wer könnte ein Motiv haben Jakob zu
entführen
auch der Erpresserbrief wird genau
untersucht es wird zum Beispiel kein
Lebenszeichen versprochen auf die
weiteren Forderungen sind eher
dilettantisch der Schreiber oder die
Schreiberin scheint kein Profi zu sein
was für die Familie nach einer guten
Nachricht klingt macht der Polizei
sorgen
Profis sind meist nur um Geld
interessiert bei einem Amateur könnte es
unter dem immer größer werdenden Druck
zu unkontrollierten Taten und
Übersprungshandlung kommen um das Kind
nicht zu gefährden werden alle
Forderungen erfüllt
dann heißt es warten
was niemand weiß jakob ist schon längst
tot
das Lösegeld wird wie gewünscht drei
Tage später am Sonntagabend in einer
aldi-tüte im Frankfurter Stadtwald
abgelegt auch hier ist die Polizei immer
dabei und observiert das Waldstück
großflächig
gegen 1:10 nähert sich ein junger Mann
er nimmt die Tüte geht einige hundert
Meter weiter zu einem kleinen See und
zählt dort das Geld auch den Hand
geschriebenen Brief des Vaters muss er
jetzt gefunden haben
bitte behandeln Sie meinen Sohn gut und
lassen Sie ihn frei
der Mann verstaut alles wieder in der
Tüte geht weiter zu einem Auto steigt
ein und fährt davon sofort wird das
Nummernschild im Polizeisystem
eingegeben und der Name des Täters
erscheint
Magnus gevin
wohnhaft nur wenige hundert Meter vom
Anwesen der Metzlers entfernt
die Familie wird in Kenntnis gesetzt und
ist entsetzt sie kennen den 27-Jährigen
Magnus gfkim ist ein unscheinbarer fast
zwei Meter großer schlagsiger junger
Mann mit Jugendlichen glattengesicht er
studiert Jura und steht kurz vor seinem
ersten Staatsexamen ein
überdurchschnittlich kluger Mensch der
aussieht als könnte er keiner Fliege was
zu leidet tun
Schwiegermutters Liebling kann man sagen
aber der erste Eindruck täuscht denn
Magnus Fassade ist eben halt nur das
eine Fassade mir was wissen wir denn
über den Studenten
Magnus kommt aus einfachen Verhältnissen
im sonst eher noblen Stadtteil
Sachsenhausen bewohnt seine Familie eine
einfache Wohnung quasi Tür an Tür mit
den Reichen und Schönen sein Vater ist
Ingenieur die Mutter kümmert sich um das
Kind und erzieht Magnus liebevoll
als der Vater arbeitslos wird beginnt er
zu trinken und die Mutter geht beten
Magnus ist als Jugendlicher auch fest in
der Gemeinde integriert er ist Kinder
und Jugendgruppenleiter und bei den
Kleinen sehr beliebt nicht so bei seinen
Klassenkameraden dort wird der gehänselt
hat kaum Freunde und gilt als verklemmt
und introvertiert
Anerkennung erfährt er nur in der
Kirchengemeinde
auch später fühlt Magnus sich mehr zu
jüngeren als Gleichaltrigen hingezogen
als Student wird der Teil der
sogenannten Ibiza Clique er verachtet
seine Familienverhältnisse und beginnt
damit Lügengeschichten zu erfinden in
denen er reich ist und von einer großen
Anwaltskanzlei bereits Vorauszahlungen
erhält bald wird er dort auch anfangen
zu arbeiten so erzählt es
in Wirklichkeit verpasste das Geld aus
einem Rentenfonds den sein Vater für ihn
angelegt hat
die ibiza-klicke besteht aus
Jugendlichen aus der wohlhabenden
Nachbarschaft als scheinbar reicher
smarter Jura Student ist er hier endlich
wer
er genießt die Aufmerksamkeit der rund
zehn Jahre jüngeren Kids schmeißt abends
einige Runden im Club und lässt sich in
die Willen der Eltern auf Ibiza einladen
rauschende Feste werden gefeiert auch
Frauen stehen plötzlich auf ihn oder
viel mehr Mädchen
zur Zeit des Falls ist der 27-Jährige
Magnus mit der
16-Jährigen Kater zusammen einer
Schulkameradin von Jakobs Schwester und
Magnus tut alles um diesen Mädchen zu
gefallen er lebt auf Pump um vor ihr
protzen zu können und einen scheinbar
reiches Leben zu leben
vor der Tat hat er seine Freundin gerade
zu einem Urlaub nach Florida eingeladen
indem sie die Outlets leer geschockt
haben und Magnus Konto er ist pleite
wir gehen zurück zur Geldübergabe
endlich hat Magnus wieder Kohle er fährt
mit dem Auto direkt zu einem
Bankautomaten und zahlt 800 Euro vom
Lösegeld auf sein eigenes Konto ein die
Überwachungskameras zeichnen alles auf
die Polizei ist auch nicht weit
von jetzt an wird jeder von Magnus
Schritten überwacht man hofft darauf
dass der junge Mann die Polizei zum
Versteck von Jakob führt aus Angst das
Leben des entführten zu gefährden hält
man sich bedeckt und beobachtet zunächst
aus der Ferne
Magnus fährt jetzt nach Hause legt sich
ins Bett und es geschieht
nichts keine Spur von Jakob
der Student steigt am nächsten Morgen es
ist mittlerweile Montag früh in sein
Auto holt seine Freundin ab und fährt er
hatte schon shoppen
erst geht es nach Aschaffenburg und
Magnus bestellt sich in einem Autohaus
einen Mercedes SLK Neupreis um die
150.000 €. dann geht es weiter in ein
Reisebüro und das Paar bucht sich einen
Urlaub auf die Kanaren
danach schlendern Sie über die
Frankfurter Einkaufsmeile Zeil und
gönnen sich einen exklusiven
Friseurbesuch
die Geduld der Polizei neigt sich dem
Ende zu als gäffgen am Nachmittag am
Frankfurter Flughafen einen Leihwagen
mietet reicht es den Beamten im Parkhaus
schießen Sie Magnus die Luft aus den
Reifen und verhaften ihn
endlich und der kleine Jakob ist da
bereits seit vier Tagen verschwunden ein
Hoffen und Bangen ob der Junge noch lebt
gegen 18 Uhr beginnen die Vernehmungen
zunächst versucht es der Ermittler auf
die nette Tour bietet Magnus dass du an
und versucht ein Vertrauensverhältnis
aufzubauen aber Mirko das haut nicht
wirklich hin ne nein Natalie leider
nicht der erfahrene Polizist appelliert
an das Gewissen Gäfgens und bittet ihn
wieder und wieder den Aufenthaltsort von
jakobreis zu geben zur gleichen Zeit
durchsuchen Spezialisten Geld ins
Wohnungen in der Hoffnung eine Spur zu
dem Jungen zu finden auch hier kein
Erfolg
sie finden lediglich das Lösegeld
versteckt den Schachteln von
Gesellschaftsspielen
im Polizeirevier erzählt Kevin
mittlerweile ein großer unbekannter
hätte ihm 20.000 Euro angeboten damit
gevin die Tüte aus dem Wald abholt
ja genau was für ein Schwachsinn das
checkt die Polizei natürlich auch sofort
dass das frei erfunden ist der Ermittler
ändert seine verhört Taktik und schiebt
Magnus Gavin ein Zettel zu legt ihm ein
Stift hin und dreht sich um
auf dem Papier stehen drei Fragen
befindet sich Jakob irgendwo allein
ist der unter Bewachung oder Aufsicht
oder befindet er sich nicht mehr am
Leben
Magnus kreuzt anders Jakob von irgendwem
bewacht wird der Polizeipsychologe wird
über den Verlauf des Verhörs informiert
und der ist sich sicher gevin spricht
nicht die Wahrheit
die Polizei beschließt an die
Öffentlichkeit zu gehen und bittet mit
einem Fahndungsaufruf um Mithilfe
wer hat Jakob gesehen wer kann etwas zu
einem möglichen Aufenthaltsort sagen
Hinweise werden rund um die Uhr
entgegengenommen
der Druck auf die Ermittler wächst über
allem steht die quälende Frage ist Jakob
noch am Leben
Polizei Vizepräsident Daschner
beschließt gegen 22 Uhr dass nun mit
härteren Mitteln vorgegangen werden muss
er ordnet eine härtere Gangart in der
Vernehmung an zur Not auch mit
unmittelbarem Zwang
übersetzt heißt das offenbar so viel wie
jetzt dürft ihr bei der Befragung
gewaltabwenden
und dann endlich ein Hinweis von gfkin
gegen Mitternacht nennt Magnus den Namen
zweier Brüder er sagt die haben Jakob
entführt und der Junge befindet sich in
einer Hütte am Langener Waldsee
große Aufregung jetzt muss alles schnell
gehen ein schwer bewaffnetes
Einsatzkommando stürmt die Wohnung der
Ahnungslosen Geschwister und fast 1000
Polizisten untersuchen das Gelände rund
um den Waldsee
[Applaus]
viel Lärm um nichts
er stellt sich heraus dass es eine
Vorgeschichte zu Magnus und einem der
Brüder gibt als 17-Jähriger soll er
zunächst eng mit dem damals 11-jährigen
befreundet gewesen sein
diese Freundschaft endet allerdings
damit dass Magnus immer aufdringlicher
wurde und sich schließlich bei einer
Übernachtung neben den jungen gelegt und
onaniert haben soll die Mutter des
Jungen informiert daraufhin die Mutter
von Magnus und das Jugendamt wird
eingeschaltet
Magnus bestreitet das alles bis heute
hegt aber scheinbar auch zehn Jahre
später noch Groll gegen seinen
ehemaligen Freund
so stark dass er versucht ihm und seinem
Bruder die Entführung anzuhängen
dieser Versuch misslingt
jetzt schaltet sich Magnus Mutter ein
und fleht ihren Sohn an ihr solle doch
endlich die Wahrheit sagen
spätestens jetzt sind sich die Ermittler
fast sicher
jakob ist nicht mehr am Leben
dann ein Hoffnungszeichen gegen 28 am
Dienstagmorgen findet die Polizei am See
doch eine vermeintliche Spur ein
Kinderschlafsack mit blutähnlichen
Spuren liegt in einer der Hütten
liegt Jakob vielleicht schwer verletzt
in einem anderen Versteck
Polizei
finden koste es was es wolle er ordnet
erneut und umgehend eine
außergewöhnliche Vernehmung an
wie das Verhör dann tatsächlich
weitergegangen ist ist bis heute nicht
sicher
fakt ist das Magnus gevkin allein mit
einem Ermittler im Raum gewesen ist und
10 Minuten später gestanden hat
Geffken bricht zusammen und sagt endlich
die Wahrheit
jetzt ist es traurige Gewissheit
jakob ist nicht mehr am Leben seine
Leiche liegt versteckt unter einem
Badesteg an einem kleinen Privatsee im
ca 100 km entfernten schauerwald
Magnus kennt den Ort von vergangenen
Sommerpartys
er führt die Polizei selbst zur Stelle
und soll sich sichtlich erschüttert
gezeigt und geweint haben
der Fall ist gelöst und lässt die
Familie des Jungen die Polizei und die
ganze Nation fassungslos zurück über
allem steht das warum
man hofft auf den Prozess und Antworten
des Mörders
der beginnt im April 2003 und verläuft
ganz anders als die meisten das erwartet
hätten alle haben auf einen umfassendes
Geständnis und einen von Reue
gezeichneten Magnus gehofft
der überrascht allerdings mit
pietätlosem Selbstmitleid hauptsächlich
geht es in seinem Geständnis um ihn
selbst das Opfer von Polizei Gewalt und
das ist der letzte Dreh an diesem Fall
genau denn nun kommt es fast zur
Einstellung des Prozesses weil das
Geständnis beim Verhör unter
Gewaltandrohung stattgefunden haben soll
es kommt heraus dass Polizei
Vizepräsident da Schneider dem
Hauptkommissar den Auftrag gegeben hat
geffgen durch Zufügung von Schmerzen zu
einer Aussage zu bewegen und den
Aufenthaltsort des Kindes preiszugeben
daraufhin entscheidet das Gericht das
alle Geständnisse die vor dem Prozess
abgelegt worden sind nicht verwendbar
sind
wow das ist so krass du weißt du hast
den Mörder des Kindes vor dir sitzen du
weißt er hat den jungen kaltblütig
umgebracht gelogen die Polizei verarscht
und zeigt dazu einfach keine Reue und
dann steht der Prozess auch noch kurz
vor dem Aus das muss der absolute Horror
sein für die Familie der ist immer
und bis heute sorgt die Anordnung
daschnas für geteilte Meinung die einen
sagen richtig so er wollte halt alles
dafür tun um das Kind lieben zu retten
da ist jedes Mittel recht
andere sagen nein Folter oder auch nur
die Androhung dessen ist eine Straftat
und niemand hat das Recht dazu dieses
Mittel zu nutzen
Magnus gevgen behauptet er sei auf die
Anordnung hin geschlagen und aus übelste
bedroht worden
der Ermittler behauptet dass es alles
gelogen es sei nichts von all dem
Geschehen
so oder so gibt es für Daschner eine
Verwarnung und Geldstrafe auf Bewährung
er verliert sein Posten und wird
versetzt und geht im Juli 2008
verbittert in den Ruhestand
der Prozess gegen Magnus gfkem wird
fortgesetzt und es kommt zu Verurteilung
[Musik]
jetzt kommt die ganze furchtbare
Wahrheit ans Licht
Magnus gesteht alles wenn auch nach wie
vor unter großem Selbstmitleid und sich
selbst als Opfer darstellend
am Tag morgen wartet geffgen nicht zum
ersten Mal auf Jakob er sei hin und
hergerissen gewesen ob er es wirklich
tun solle aber am nächsten Tag würde
Jakob in den Urlaub fahren Magnus ist
pleite also muss es heute passieren
nachdem Jakob in Magnus Auto gestiegen
ist plaudern sie über Eintracht
Frankfurt und die bevorstehenden Ferien
kaum in der Wohnung angekommen fesselt
Magnus den Jungen und klebt im Mund und
Nase zu
die Klebestreifen dafür hat er bereits
vorher vorbereitet und bereit gelegt
Magnus behauptet er hätte eigentlich
nicht vorgehabt Jakob umzubringen als
dieser aber anfängt zu schreien um sich
zu treten und zu zappeln setzt es bei
seinem Kidnapper aus
Magnus gevken drückt minutenlang seine
Hände auf Jakobs Gesicht bis sich dieser
nicht mehr bewegt
danach zieht er den Jungen aus und
taucht den leblosen Körper in der
Badewanne unter Wasser um zu sehen ob
noch Luft aufsteigt
jetzt ist er sich ganz sicher jakob ist
tot
er wickelt die Leiche in Tüten und ein
Bettlaken packt sie in seinen Kofferraum
und fährt los auf dem Weg zum Versteck
fährt er am Garten der von Metzlers
vorbei und wirft in der presserbrief
über den Zaun
von der Entführung bis zu diesem
Zeitpunkt sind nicht mehr als eineinhalb
Stunden vergangen
es ist so grausam und schrecklich und
skrupellos und deswegen mir einfach
nicht in den Kopf dieser junge Mann mit
dem Baby face hat fast sein jurorexamen
in der Tasche ein Mann der eigentlich
alle Möglichkeiten im Leben hat und dann
diese schreckliche Tat begeht und dann
ist auch noch so skrupellos dabei ja und
dumm also wow wie konnte er bitte denken
dass das alles nicht rauskommt also
allein dass er das Lösegeld voll
laufenden bankkameras einzahlt und mit
seinem eigenen Auto die Kohle abholt das
lernt man doch in jedem Krimi Film da
sowas gar nicht geht also
ja dem Jungen den kann man nichts
vorwerfen ich meine wir kennen das alle
aus der Kindheit mama Papa sagen geh
nicht mit Fremden mit aber der war ja
kein Fremder das war ja der nette
Bekannte der Schwester der Jura Student
aus der Nachbarschaft was soll da schon
passieren
bei diesem Fall überkommt mich pure Wut
aber das einzig gute an dieser ganzen
Dummheit ist das Magnus gfkind dadurch
zumindest geschnappt werden konnte und
hoffentlich nie wieder aus dem Gefängnis
rauskommt
im Juli 2003 fällt das Urteil
lebenslänglich mit besonderer Schwere
der Schuld eine vorzeitige Entlassung
nach 15 Jahren ist damit ausgeschlossen
im Gefängnis studiert Magnus Kevin
weiter macht sein Jura staatssexamen und
versucht immer wieder eine frühere
Entlassung einzuklagen bis heute
erfolglos er ändert seinen Namen in
Thomas David Lukas Olsen weil sein
echter Name zu bekannt ist und ihn alle
mit dem kindsmarkt in Zusammenhang
bringen
dieses kuppelosigkeit finde ich
unglaublich erschreckenend er zeigt
überhaupt kein Anzeichen von heuer im
Gefängnis hatte ein Buch geschrieben
über sich selbst und stellt sich wieder
als Opfer staatlicher Gewalt da auch das
zeigt finde ich dass er offensichtlich
nicht in der Lage ist seine Tat wirklich
zu reflektieren und in erster Linie
Bedauern und Mitgefühl zu zeigen das
Buch das er geschrieben hat heißt
übrigens allein mit Gott der Weg zurück
tja keiner will es lesen zu Recht
er tänzelt ständig zwischen Arroganz und
Selbstmitleid hin und her
seinen geschmacklosen Höhepunkt findet
das Ganze übrigens als er die
gäfchen-stiftung für junge Gewaltopfer
gründen will und sich wundert dass die
zuständige Behörde das natürlich absolut
daneben findet und die Gründung ablehnt
Magnus kefken ist ein Mörder der bis
heute keine Einsicht zeigt und für mich
eindeutig für immer hinter Gitter gehört
dieser Typ der hat sie echt nicht alle
also was fällt ihm ein damit beenden wir
die heutige Folge wir danken euch fürs
zuhören und freuen uns wenn ihr auch
beim nächsten Mal wieder dabei seid bei
Tatort Deutschland Spezial eure Natalie
und eure Mirko
diesen Fall haben wir mit Hilfe von Bild
und fokusartikeln der Dokumentation die
großen Kriminalfälle Jakob von Metzler
Tod eines bankiersohns sowie des
zdf-films Jakob von Metzler recherchiert
Redaktion Stefan Netzeband und Antonia
Heyer Produktion Marvin schwarz